you know I just say hired Dwayne Johnson
to take over all these failing action
franchises because the rock GI Joe
retaliation is the sequel to the truly
awful GI Joe rise of the Cobra yes I
really hated that movie I saw in
theaters I hated it I really did not
like that movie was directed by Stephen
Sommers in that movie just o GI Joe rise
the Cobra whoo this movie is directed by
someone new Jon M Chu now he directed a
few step up movies now you may be
thinking oh boy that's not a good sign
but I will say that despite the fact
those movies are also really silly
cheesy teenage drama films they look
great
like those step up movies look fantastic
with really slick Direction especially
the third one so with this movie all I
wanted was for it to be better than the
last one that's honestly all I want to
just please please be better than the
last one now the plot of this film is
essentially all of the GI Joes just
about are wiped out there's only a few
remaining ones the rock is now the
leader of these people and he has to go
out and try to fight against Cobra who's
taken over the White House you got snake
eyes in there you got storm shadow and
even Bruce Willis as Joe himself and
they're gonna go to war against Cobra to
retaliate against the people who killed
their friends so is this movie better
than the first one yes I really do think
it is is it a great movie no is it a
good movie I wouldn't even say that it's
just a completely mindless action film
is it a terrible movie I could see why
you would say that if you walked out of
this movie and thought it was awful
there's I wouldn't be surprised at all I
would just be like up yeah that's fine
that's cool I for one found the film to
be a watchable mindless movie experience
because I didn't go into GI Joe
retaliation expecting Schindler's List
because I know that it's just it's a
movie based off of toys and a cartoon
from the 80s in other words it's
transformers so you know there are tons
of problems with this movie there are
characters in the film that I don't even
really know what the confrontations are
about because I think you actually kind
of have to know a little bit about the
cartoon and those characters to be able
to understand some of the depths behind
these people's emotions and who they
don't like and who's fighting who and
who is good and who is bad there's times
in the movie where it's a little
confusing for someone who isn't entirely
versed in GI Joe lore like myself
and I only saw the first film once back
in 2009 because I never wanted to
experience again there's a few times
this movie I was watching and I was like
wait what but for the most part this
really is just a mindlessly fun
entertaining film and it's directed much
better than the first one you can
actually see some of the action which is
cool the first one was just like what
was what was going in the first one that
was that was in there I think yeah
that's what stands out about the first
one to me a CGI polar bear that's saying
something in this film there is actually
some good action sequences that are fun
yes all of the technology in this film
does not exist anywhere on this planet
and the political scenes in the film
origin if anyone actually thinks that's
how the government works mmm good things
in this film are the fact that it is
watchable and entertaining in my opinion
it's a fun experience despite the fact
that it is extremely dumb Dwayne Johnson
is the best part of this movie he's
great he really is doing really well
he's kind of becoming this generations
action hero and I thought he did great
in this movie too for what he needed to
be he was funny he was likable and he
was good in the action scenes now one of
my major issues with this movie isn't
really a spoiler but I'm going to act
like it is simply because I don't know
if you've watched the trailer if you've
seen the trailer for this movie you know
that certain characters do not make it
that long in this movie if you haven't
seen the trailer I won't say who it is
as the film starts out there's a great
camaraderie on display between a few of
the characters and I really like the
direction the film was taking and it was
really entertaining and very funny and I
liked it back and forth now as I told
you a lot of the GI Joes get wiped out
and when some of those characters got
removed I thought the film lost
something I thought that maybe if there
was a way they could have kept some of
those characters around for much longer
perhaps maybe even longer into the film
or even the whole movie I think the film
would have been better and more
entertaining there was really good
chemistry between some of these
characters and I missed that when those
characters weren't around anymore I
understand the movie had to have that
Agent Coulson moment you know the moment
in the Avengers where everyone was like
oh it's on it just got real now this
movie had to have one of those moments
to get the characters to do what they
had to do I just wish that maybe it was
different
Bruce Willis inclusion in the film is
extremely minimal he really doesn't have
that much to do in this movie you can
tell that he was just maybe there for a
few days of supporting work and
everything and now he's on all the
posters it's nice to have his prey
there he certainly doesn't detract from
the movie it's just he's not really
there that much as I said Dwayne
Johnson's character roadblock he's
really entertaining but his two partners
Flint and Lady Jane they're like
completely underdeveloped I don't care
at all about them they could have all
been shot early on in the film and I
wouldn't have really cared at all
Lady Jane honestly looks like a porn
star throughout half of this movie and I
could not take her seriously at all
nevertheless I did have an enjoyable
time watching this movie it was mindless
entertainment is it going to make me
like the biggest GI Joe fan in the world
no but I did have a good time watching
the film for the most part and for that
reason I'm gonna give it a b-minus I'm
not going to say rush out and see this
movie I'm going to say that if you
wanted to see a GI Joe movie that is
better than the first one
you probably will is it a great movie at
all no but it's definitely not trying to
be anything that it's not also the 3d
was fine it wasn't terrible it wasn't
anything great but it wasn't really a
deterrence to the movie I don't know if
it was necessary I would say you could
see it in 2d or 3d and be perfectly fine
with that thanks as always for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my next
[Music]
Oh